hello and welcome to women with balls
where i can talk to today's trailblazers
my guest i was born in south london but
northumberland is her adopted home where
she now lives and serves as the local mp
a headstrong child her political
awakening can be traced back to a young
age and the influence of thatcher after
graduating she became a chartered
accountant at pwc but politics was in
her sights she won the conservative seat
for barack von tweed in the 2015
election a historic liberal democrats
hold
at first she was a thorn on the
government side as a member of the
european research group but under boris
johnson she has been rapidly promoted
and developed a reputation as one of his
most trusted colleagues
she is known as the determined cabinet
minister who can take big outward-facing
briefs such as her current one in charge
of britain's post brexit trade strategy
she says when you've got a character
like mine when stuff that's wrong is
profoundly irritating and doing
something about it is how i want to fix
things this is the job
my guest stays amber avery freddie
andrew thank you for coming on this
podcast today we had it pencilled in i
think about a year or so ago but then
you rudely were promoted
and the green light we had for you to
speak to us uh had to be put put on hold
as you as you got to your new brief
i think that's a nice way of putting it
i haven't been in the country much but
it's lovely to be here
um now on this podcast we always begin
by saying uh would you describe yours as
a happy childhood
i had a very happy childhood uh and
amazing my dad died when i was two so i
was brought up by my amazing and very
long suffering mother
and her mum my granny so we were a team
of three invincible girls and i was
reading about um your personality as a
child and i think you had did you have a
t-shirt that said boss on it yes it was
came to me when i was two and it says
the boss i still have it it's very small
doesn't fit anymore but i've kept it and
i think my mother and in fact everyone
else uh viewed that as a perfect
description of me i was clear and
determined and i think probably made
everyone's life for misery unless uh i
succeeded in my missions
so in the
household of free ladies um so i imagine
as you say uh developing strong
personality from an early age did you
have big ambitions um did your uh you
know mother uh try and spur you on to do
big things
no the only uh sense i suppose was that
education was really important and i was
expected to work hard uh which i did i
think i was naturally curious i was one
of those children that always asked why
again and again and again and when i say
my mother was long suffering that's one
of the reasons why i was always curious
i was wanting to want to learn more so
education was a joy for me and i had the
extraordinary privilege thanks to
actually um friends of my fathers who
funded it
to be able to be educated at some pools
girls school which is a school in london
which genuinely thrives on uh
stimulating uh the young women there to
think for themselves to be creative to
push the boundaries so i was very very
lucky were you demanding of answers were
you badly behaved
i didn't think i was badly behaved
stress on parents i think i was probably
quite tiring for mother because i was uh
always curious but she uh is
she's a writer and uh she was always
there i mean my granny used to take me
uh away to her house for the weekend so
maybe that was the therapy that my
mother needed to recover from the ever
demanding child but i think i was fairly
easy going uh i had a cat and i was very
happy being an only child i didn't know
any different
so i was very good at you know
entertaining myself when i still am i
like my own company now you went on to
study at oxford polytechnic and you
studied maths um at that point were you
at all political or were you
were you thinking career-wise and in
particular
no so when i was at school i'd thought i
wanted to be a doctor my grandfather was
a doctor
but i was really a bit rubbish at
chemistry so when chemistry level fell
off the opportunity list uh becoming a
doctor therefore wasn't an option so i
followed my uh natural instinct for
maths and for numbers and for logic uh
which i love and studied maths uni which
was fabulous i loved it it was pure
maths degree in of itself completely
useless other than developing your uh
logic skills and your in fact your
argumentative skills which probably my
mother would say already had so i love
that but i think politics are such not
in focus i'd become politically aware as
a child uh but i don't think i'd ever
thought that one could be an mp that
wasn't a sort of a place that i would go
did it interest me yes i was fascinated
by people that did i thought it was for
people cleverer than me to become mps
now you're at oxford polytechnic and of
course there's also oxford university
was there much crossover um when you're
there at the time because obviously
you've had you know lots of your
colleagues today in cabinet room at
oxford university did the two mix so
there was i mean socially lots of mixing
you know oxford is a city full of
students and there's lots of mixing so i
got involved in the oxford union uh
eddie vasey had been he'd been at some
pools the boys school with me so i knew
him quite well
and i started going to the union because
i was fascinated by these debates these
you know incredibly erudite young people
uh who could debate there's not a skill
i'd done at all at school being a
scientist
and that's where i got to know people
like michael gove who became you know
real friends for life
and i watched you know amazed as they uh
debated black was white and white was
green and green was orange and i
couldn't quite understand how that was
possible but it was a joy to watch and i
was yeah genuinely fascinated but didn't
see it as
something that would be for me
so you leave university and you qualify
as an accountant for pwc
um what's the workplace like at that
time is it is it quite like
male heavy is it quite a mix
is it fun it was great fun so yes i
joined the city in 1990 uh in the heart
of the city price waterhouse as it was
then
we were probably i can't remember
exactly but i'd probably say probably 30
women in my cohort
but a very egalitarian perspective uh pw
was very forward thinking uh training to
be a chance account is just bloody hard
work the nice possible way you work you
know 12 hour days and then you go home
and you study for three or four every
day it's a fairly brutal schedule uh
good training for being an mp the
relentlessness of work but it was
fascinating and uh i was uh you get you
get to select an area of industry that
you want to be involved in as you're
training and i chose manufacturing i was
fascinated by stuff being made so i got
to go to all part all sorts of parts of
the country to do audits and to you know
do reviews with businesses uh who are
price waterhouse clients and i think
that's probably where i got my first
taste
of you know having been brought up as a
london girl this amazing network of uh
industry across our country i think
that's probably gave me that first taste
of uh how important the uk is across the
country not just london which is what
i'd known as a child and then you
eventually relocate to northumberland
1996 to serve as governor of the
healthcare trust um what why did you
make that move did you want to get out
of london
so i fell in love the old-fashioned the
old-fashioned reason for moving
and uh moved up to northumberland so i i
found a new job in newcastle working
actually in corporate finance again
actually an opportunity to discover the
industry of the northeast which i didn't
really know what i discovered it was the
most fascinating thing so the size of
companies shrank so where i've been
dealing with city businesses with you
know let's say 10 knots on it in the
northeast they had six notes on it so
they were much smaller their focus
wasn't about the size of the company it
was about their people and i was totally
entranced by that and so i was doing uh
you know helping them buy and sell
companies and the only important thing
was their people so they wanted to make
sale that was fine but if they didn't
like the people who were going to buy
the company they didn't sell it because
they were too concerned by the people it
was a really awakening moment that
actually there was a part of the country
that still thought people first not
money i'd been brought up through the
80s through the kind of you know the big
bang and uh you know my training in the
city was through the 90s and then i
there i was uh in an environment which
said people are still your most
important asset it was a absolute joy
and i was i was transfixed that's it i
was i'm a northeast girl ever since yes
you preferred that so you know buy
london
completely 100 yeah i was going to stay
there and never come back
and so at what point then did you decide
that a you want to be an mp but i
suppose also you want to be a
conservative mp did the conservative
answer become before the mp1
so i've always been a conservative i'd
always voted conservative i have a
i think you know a strong set of values
about if you uh you should be
self-sufficient you should work hard but
you should be you know entitled to uh
reap the you know the benefits of yours
and you need those views by the time
you're at university oh yeah without
stat i think i think as a as a very
young teenager i had a a strong sense of
that always always a strong believer so
uh my uh granny's father had been a
vicar and a teacher and i think she
instilled in me that sense of safetyness
and looking after those who couldn't
with themselves so i had a very strong
sense of
uh
care for those that need it but also
that everyone else should just get on
and use their skills and do the best
they can so i think that was i was
instinctively a conservative in that
sense and i voted conservative i don't
think i ever didn't vote conservative
not as i can remember
um i have friends who occasionally vote
green to wind me up and i think oh
actually now i can see that but i never
did always voted conservative uh but i
was
did i think i'm gonna be no i became
involved in local
activities um in northumberland
uh
the governor of the of the of the school
of the healthcare trust uh where i could
you know make a difference whilst i had
small children we were busy running two
family businesses
and the more i got involved the more i
realized that if you want to make change
you just have to be in the room it's
that simple actually don't range about
something if you want to make change get
involved so i was getting involved and
then
i was involved in the local
conservatives association because my
mother-in-law was and you sort of you
know you helped leave it at election
times and i did a couple of those
uh you know just with friends in a very
non-political way i had very small
children and lots of other things to do
and then in
2005 when david cameron
became leader of the party i got a text
from michael gove saying right it's our
generation's term now emery come on
you've got to get involved i said
michael i'm in the northeast which is
all red let's be clear
uh and i've got two small children i'm
running two businesses don't be
ridiculous he said you've got to get
involved
so i said all right i'll i'll put myself
forwards i said thinking not a chance to
my earlier point that i thought you know
uh there was no chance that i was up for
it anyway i passed the selection board
much to my surprise maybe i shouldn't
have been surprised but i was uh perhaps
there's a difference in there that you
know we don't see anymore but it was an
honest surprise uh and then i was you
know asked professor and i i'd very
clear in my own mind
if i was going to do this there was any
chance i was happy to stand i didn't
think for him i'd ever get elected i
wanted to represent where i lived and
the people you know my family and my
friends and the communities where my
children were being brought up and you
know the world that was mine so i stood
i put myself forward for a number of
other seats but you know didn't get
selected for which actually i was quite
grateful because what i really wanted
was to be uh the candidate of berkeley
want to eat and they were kind enough to
select me and if this was in 2006 i
didn't think for a moment that we could
overturn what had been a 40-year liberal
democrat seat and in 2010 indeed we
didn't but we made huge strides and that
was a really interesting discovery for
me which was i was putting myself out
there completely as a volunteer you know
busy running my business day to day
uh that actually
people wanted someone who was willing to
stand up for them and you know take the
battering and you know beat down walls
and it was a matter of trust and so i
carried on through from 2010 2015 as the
candidate fighting for things that
needed fixing discovering that actually
you can get stuff done even without
being the mp in some levels which is you
know very gratifying and great for the
communities i was working for and then
in 2015 uh i was elected
which was really exciting a little bit
disconcerting to be honest because i
generally didn't think we could turn the
northeast blue and i was perhaps the you
know first blue
brick in in that wall which is now much
bluer
yeah and you've kept it since then so
far so good
you enter parliament in 2015.
and now you're someone who is a
brexiteer
uh i wondered entering politics you're
talking about all the kind of the local
issues how you want to stand up for your
constituencies and why it was so
important for that reason you had the
city that you went on to have
quite quickly brexit starts to dominate
did you have any sense when you entered
the
or did you did you plan for that to be
the thing that you spend most of your
time on because for example we had your
your cabinet colleague stella braverman
on recently and obviously she took on a
really big role and that was also in the
erg
and she's saying you know she had so
many other things she actually want to
talk about when she came into parliament
but before you know it if it's a course
close to your heart you end up letting
that job in most of your time uh i think
that's a very fair challenge so we you
know we all arrived soon and i were you
know the 2015 intake together
and we had another thing so i had some
issues about ambulance services and i
was able to raise those early on uh and
to my amazement discover that you could
genuinely make a difference as a
backbencher was that that was one of the
most
empowering moments actually to really
feel that happen and to change national
policy as a result of something awful
that had happened in my own patch uh but
yes as you say uh there was this you
know developing narrative and of course
part of our manifesto had been that we
would uh bring a referendum so this this
running
activity about that came through we
brought the legislation in um
because of course david cameron had been
to
uh brussels to try and negotiate what
were looking back on it four very small
reforms that he was asking for and in
not getting them he went do you know
what the british people won't stand for
that anymore
uh and so i had always been brexit here
so i have my mother is half french very
french uh and you speak i speak fluent
french yes you have to when you've got
you know 32 cousins uh it's the only way
to keep up with them all and
i love i love what my family do i love
france i love europe but i thought i've
always thought the eu construct was
just not suited to the uk that we
weren't able to flourish as much as
we you know i felt we can as a country
and that actually we were you know
perhaps being a useful part of a group
of 28 countries but actually for the uk
that wasn't necessarily
the right thing so i was a very you know
happy and comfortable brexiteer
i think what uh surprised me and i blame
steve baker completely
is he was obviously as a older and wiser
mp looking for those uh who would help
you know the brexit group and he asked
me to join uh the conservative grouping
for brexit and i naively said yes
and having done that because i was happy
to talk about it and stand up for you
know a principle which i was very
comfortable with uh found myself thrust
into the limelight both of um the erg
which is sort of if you like the
internal mps uh you know brexit group
but also the vote leave campaign
and i became a director of vote leave
and
i championed all the work around women
for britain
and working across the country with our
amazing cohort of volunteers who came
out to champion what was this
extraordinary weird thing called a
referendum and yes that very much filled
a lot of my time but it never it never
stopped that continuum the beauty of
being an mp and i say that when i travel
the world now people say very short
visit i say i have to get back it's
friday and i have to be my constituency
on friday and people look a bit bemused
when you're talking to you know leaders
and rulers and they say oh i said
because that is the anchor which makes
you an mp everything else you do
however big or small is very important
but your constituency is always your
anchor so the beauty even through the
brexit referendum which you know had a
lot of noise and you know it was quite
brutal in a number of ways actually
always on a friday at home with my patch
where obviously through the referendum
there was a lot of talk about brexit but
you know it was in the annex car park uh
you know it was outside the school in
beric it was in the mart in willa it was
in the patch so always grounded in what
my constituents felt and i used to come
back to london on monday and go and see
the vote leave team and see matthew
elliott and dominic cummings and the
team there and they'd be like oh you
know it feels really difficult i'd say
trust me northeast is saying please can
we leave and it was really interesting i
brought a very strong that what we saw
then which was this incredible uh both
voting numbers and strong brexit voices
in the northeast and i used to bring it
back to london every monday morning and
sort of energize the team that actually
in the rest of the country outside the
london bubble there was a very strong
support for brexit um it's interesting
you mentioned vote leave and i remember
um well we had those dominant comings
blogs i think during the eu referendum
slightly and then when he entered dining
street and i remember always thinking
you were one of the only mps he had
something positive to say about
yes i believe that may be true
i mentioned the european research group
and obviously the result comes the
result is leaved
listeners will know what happens next
teresa becomes prime minister starts off
a strong rhetoric begins to go downhill
and um
i want to talk about your role in the
european research group um
you were a pps
the first at 1.4 um in the ministry of
defense um but you left that role over
theresa may's brexit withdrawal
agreement
um was that was that a difficult
decision did you face much pressure from
your colleagues of course pps
resignations aren't treated like cabinet
resignations but i think there's still
you know something that is not welcomed
by the government
so
no it's always difficult when you're you
know everything is uh successful in
politics because you play as a team if
the team fragments you're less likely to
be successful
but in the brexit space i had always
been a very you know honest and open
brexiteer and i did feel that uh theresa
may's proposition simply wasn't going to
deliver
a genuine brexit which for me was really
important and indeed the erg sort of
held the you know held the anchor on
what a
a full brexit which meant we were free
of eu ties would mean so uh when it
became clear that that you know the
proposition on the table wasn't one i it
wasn't it wasn't difficult to leave i
mean i was sad to you no longer probably
but at the end of the day as i say the
only the only thing that's important uh
really is your constituents as an mp and
the person you look in the mirror in uh
in the mornings and that's yourself
and then just a final one that i
remember when we first met you're in the
elgi and i think you were doing some of
the whipping um so did your maths degree
help with that incredibly important to
be able to count beyond 150 yes
um
now
we get to a position where
ultimately boris johnson becomes prime
minister um
we know what happens with that brexit
agreement to resume fails to get it
through
and it becomes a party which is uh maybe
it's the wrong way of putting it more
proudly leave but is is going on a
clearer direction on brexit
and it's also a government where
you were suddenly seen as a rising star
and boris johnson um promotes you um
when it came to the the first role you
received i think that was defense
procurement um what was it like moving
from you know backbencher and in a way
being seen as a bit of a rebel and you
can argue that the elg was directing the
government in direction they later
adopted but at the time as i mentioned
it more than the side to suddenly having
you know collective responsibility and
all those things
so the really interesting point you make
there which is actually you should
always fight for what you believe in
because uh if
a consensus majority
lands in the same place that becomes
government policy so no one should ever
feel that their opinion isn't valid just
because it doesn't match the
government's view of the day
because that's how politics makes
progress that's how changes is affected
but yes so becoming a junior minister in
july of 2019 well was it was a huge
honor again if i thought that i was no
chance about becoming mp the idea that i
was suddenly a minister of state was
genuinely a surprise to me though
seemingly not necessarily to everybody
else which was very uh encouraging uh it
was fascinating to take on the role i'd
done a lot as about venture championing
at the armed forces covenant it was an
area i've got an raf base at my
constituency so i was very involved in
um making sure that our military
families in particular were supported uh
so it was a fascinating role looking at
literally kit kitten people and how we
manage uh the military estates uh and i
learned a great deal at pace one of the
things you discover when you become a
minister for the first time
is the uh mysterious management uh by
the civil service of its ministers and
the machinery of government
and it's definitely an apprenticeship
system you can't really know i was given
gerald kaufman's book how to be a
minister
which is fascinating very funny actually
very funny and spot on it darlene hasn't
changed at all in 25 years but the uh
important
rules about knowing what where you fit
in how government works as a minister i
think is the most important thing i
learned which is uh you direct so you're
not a you're not a chief executive
you're a chairman if you like your
directing and civil servants uh want to
work with their ministers that's really
important but it's difficult to affect
sudden change one of the challenges that
obviously the prime minister had as he
was trying to deliver brexit is that
it's it's just quite complicated to make
the machinery of government uh move at
pace into a very different direction so
i think that my my role in as defense
procurement uh was fascinating and i was
able to bring two key uh
new pieces of uh kit into into being if
that's the way you describe them and you
know real honor to know that as i now
watch it all being built and it's the
next generation of both our army and our
navy's kit that's extraordinary to think
that i was able to help
uh you know get that into place um but
it was as much as i think it was a real
apprenticeship on how the machinery of
government fits together and you
mentioned civil servants how they would
work for ministers i just wanted on that
i mean
there are some in the government who
have quite an interesting rhetoric on
civil servants and whether it's you know
working from home or i think jacob reese
morgan has recently been doing sport
check and inspections
is your view that civil servants do do
a lot of good i actually
generally speaking want to work with the
government so yes jacob i hear was
crawling through our corridors in uh
department of international trade the
other day but as i've got the top
statistics of any department mostly
because i've got a fantastic team of
young people and they were very keen to
come back to work i think we passed the
jacob rees-mob test so that was good um
civil servants are amazing people it's
an incredibly um
sort of deep relationship they have
government they have they move around
through their careers and they bring
with them this extraordinary uh
understanding of how the complexity of a
machinery of government works uh clearly
there are some who are uh you know uh
more highly skilled in certain areas i
think when uh some people say you know
they don't do what they should my
experience has been uh they're
very very uh literate very good on
policy i i've i'm always seeking out
people who are good at data analytics
who will
use data because i'm a mathematician
that's how i think so where's the data
i'll say
i you know i understand that you think
this is a great policy
and i sort of see where you're coming
from and you know your logic setting it
out but actually i need to understand it
by looking at the data and making an
analysis through those fact-based
systems so let's not say that that
doesn't happen elsewhere in the
machinery but as a minister you often
don't see that so i think if there was a
need for a broader mix of skills in the
service civil service it would be more
of that sort of analytical thinking
which is arguably what a minister is
asked to do before they take a decision
uh and i think that's where some of the
challenge comes but i've never had
anything but an amazing team of civil
servants with me in any of my
departments now you're in your second
cabinet position and because you were
international development secretary and
then it was ultimately um merged into
the foreign office so you had to i think
you took a time out of government in
between it's a bit strange going from
habit minister to back bench when but
it's not for you a sacking or a
resignation if that makes sense
so it seems it's one of the calmest ways
to move between and so it was it was a
yes it was a pause uh i had been uh as
it turned out the last international
development secretary uh through covid
and i didn't go anywhere so it was a
quite an odd uh way to be international
advertising we developed uh because of
course we had teams still across the
world who were managing you know covered
in some of the most uh poorest of
countries with the least resources
so we developed a sort of virtual
visiting system where uh my small team
who were in the office with me
would work out food or tea or flavors
and we would pretend we were like we
would beam in
and we would meet people in you know who
were in uh you know camps or working in
hospitals supporting the work that they
were doing through covet and indeed
education in particular we were trying
to continue to make sure that education
was uh keeping going in many countries
while sitting around the table uh in my
office eating or you know drinking
kenyan tea or eating you know amazing uh
iraqi cake so we had some extraordinary
ways of trying to make sure that we
could uh keep up but it was it was a
really difficult time because actually
international development and you know
the the spending of overseas development
aid was at its most you know critical
usage that i
ran the refunding of garvey which is the
vaccine initiative global vaccine
initiative uh we raised you know 20 more
than we thought we would and that was
critical to helping deliver covered
vaccines once they appeared later in the
year uh throughout some of the poorest
countries so it was an extraordinary and
you know
empowering first role as a secretary of
state but quite a strange one because it
was through covert and now i just want
to ask you a few final questions on your
current brief um before we finish this
podcast and of course you're now
secretary of state for international
trade as you mentioned earlier this
means you're often out of the country
um and we're speaking on a week where
there's obviously lots in the news about
steel tariffs
um now and the government's plan to
extend it which some say could be in the
breach of wto rules um i just wanted
someone who campaigned for brexit
you've got figures such as tom tugan um
you know you did not campaign for brexit
saying that this is you know
protectionist and this should not be
what we're
does this does this chime do you do you
understand the criticism and does it
make you uncomfortable at all the fact
that it seems a bit protectionist
so uh i hear the challenge and i would
be uh the first to say we want to have
and we do have an incredibly open uh
market we trade uh through free and fair
trade which is you know a stamp of uh uk
uh respect and why countries are queuing
up to do free trade agreements with us
because we are believers in free of fair
trade the challenge of using uh the
tariff system which we inherited when we
left the eu in terms of steel is that
there are uh some country actors in the
steel markets who are not working by a
free and fair trade systems and they
dump cheap steel into markets thereby
really disturbing
those competitive markets steel
industries are strategic
every country uh has a steel industry
because it's strategic if we needed to
we need to be able to produce steel for
our uh own purposes uh we need to make
sure we have one and it's a very
expensive uh business you know firing up
a furnace is you know millions of pounds
worth of activity so the challenge of
maintaining these uh tariffs for the
next two years uh which have rolled over
as i say from when we left the eu system
is because our steel industry does need
to have a relatively level playing field
in which to play uh to try and stop that
uh dumping of certain types of steel
these these tariffs will end in two
years time that's that's the framework
and after that
i wouldn't be able to bring an email on
so it's very much
a protection whilst the steel industry
looks to try and
build up one of the issues obviously
we're seeing not only in the uk but
across steel industries is looking to
move to clean steel using
clean energy and producing steel in a
different way and that's something that
we are working obviously led by bays we
are working very closely with our steel
mills to help them to develop
and then
there will be new ways i have no doubt
going forwards to ensure that clean
steel is the one that is uh encouraged
and sold around the world
and and just a final one that you you
don't worry that if it looks as though
the uk is kind of
breaching wto rules and obviously
there'll be defenses saying it's not um
you know reneging on international
agreements it could start to affect
future trade deals you don't think it's
going to have that impact
so the reason why i've decided to keep
these tariffs on in because my trade
remedies authority uh reviewed the whole
steel industry for me and they looked it
across the three families of steel so
flat steel uh bars of steel and tubular
steel the three different types of steel
that are made they then get turned into
all sorts of amazing things but that's
basically what comes up steel mills
and across the board with the uh both
state of steel production around the
globe but also things like energy prices
the disruptions to steel markets caused
by the
illegal invasion of ukraine by russia
it's my view that the economic test is
met to actually
keep these and that's
acceptable
and other countries are doing the same
so i'm comfortable in that position but
you know countries are free to challenge
us and indeed
that's why we have an ambassador at the
wco in geneva
there to have those discussions if
there's a need but i'm comfortable with
the decision
now last trade question is just one of
the big uk trade goals is to join the
cptp
i struggled to say yeah
practice makes perfect um
do you think we're on course to do that
this year
uh so i hope so i would never uh wish to
uh give you a precise date because at
any point a trade negotiation can meet a
meet and blocker but so far it's going
really well we passed the first stage so
we're the first country to apply to
exceed to this uh trading block so we're
sort of uh testing their frameworks
they've never done it before so the
first part was especially i couldn't
describe is like exam questions you know
do you have these laws in place what are
your labor laws all those sorts of
things so we passed that set of tests uh
in the run-up just after christmas
and now we're into the market access
discussions which are progressing well
but obviously we're having conversations
with 11 countries at a time so every
country has you know their particular
area of interest or concern so my team
are working uh diligently through that
with them and so obviously last week
when i was
in geneva for wto meetings i was able to
catch up with many of those countries
trade ministers who all gave me
assurance that we seem to be doing the
right thing and hopefully passing the
test so would i like to say i'd like to
have that as a christmas present yes
final three questions the first one is
just um there's lots of cabinet
reshuffle speculation at the moment and
obviously this happens often more than
once a year um often every few months um
but when you're looking about uh for
example in this round lots of names of
saying oh this briefing saying people
who could go
and these briefings could come from
anywhere you know quasi qua tang america
valley your name comes up
what do you do when you see that i mean
it's worth pointing out
lots of cabinet reshuffle speculation
has proven to be very wrong over the
years the number of times i've read that
liz trust was going to be sacked only
for her to become the longest serving
cabinet
minister um but do you read it do you
ignore it what do you do
so it's hard to miss because people tend
to send it to you uh but it's nice of
that they're friends and families
know team i i honestly uh my granny
taught me a long time ago that you
shouldn't believe everything you read in
the papers and that stuck the wisdom of
a granny at a young age and i'm busy
getting on with what is a genuinely
fascinating and extraordinary role you
know as a brexiteer i get to be
delivering one of the key planks of
brexit opportunity which is our own
trade policy so honestly i'm going to
get on and keep doing that uh for as
long as the prime minister wishes me to
do that uh if he wishes to move me or
send me back for about benches as he's
done before i will also be perfectly
content with that there's plenty of
things to be doing there too but i hope
to be able to carry on uh doing this
role for a while because there's loads
to do we're just getting going on our
relationship with the us uh we've got
some really interesting work uh in the
indo-pacific we've got work going on now
that we've got australian new zealand
under our belts uh to help build those
relationships so there's loads to be
doing so i hope for the time being that
he will let me crack on and do that but
uh i'm not prone to worrying too much
about what journalists think
you mentioned that you're on the first
bricks and the blue walls for the tory
party obviously we're speaking after two
by-election losses one of which was
tiffin honestly
um
lots of your colleagues are very worried
about the rise of the liberal democrats
if you look at a succession of
by-elections you know trashman amateur
and others
do you think it is a big problem the
party needs to take seriously
so there was so i fought and won against
liberal democrat uh so i'm very tuned to
their uh long-lasting abilities so when
after uh 2017 the numbers uh really
diminished 2015 and then 27 they
diminished and people said oh well you
know that's it it's all over i said no
of course it's not they are a party that
likes to work at a local level and try
and reflect that onto the national stage
uh don't for a moment think that they
won't be back and a by-election
territory is where they are at their
best because uh they don't have to be
delivering government policy they don't
have any uh you know need to for
instance the the winning uh lib dem uh
candidate in tiverton has declared that
he's going to
uh
call on the government to give a uh fuel
duty
cut well i'm thrilled about that but if
his lib dem colleagues who were mps
before him had voted with us uh he would
have been able to say the lib dems also
supported uh fuel cuts but they didn't
they voted against it so that sort of uh
ability to say one thing and do the
other is uh classic lib dem tactics uh
you know midterm by-elections you know
invariably do give the government a
hammering you know hartlepool was a
notable exception uh which was ensued
fantastic it was wonderful to welcome
jill mortimer into the house with us but
it is relatively normal for uh
by-elections midterm to see the
government of the day uh get a trouncing
and i hope very much that when the next
general election comes tiverton and
hunter will be returned blue without
question
it's probably worthwhile it is the
biggest by-election defeat in history if
you look at the numbers i think
um now just finally the final question
is when we ask everyone on this podcast
which is just what is the worst advice
you've ever been given which you kind of
ignored or you could have taken it on
board and then thought why did i follow
that
that's a really interesting question uh
i listen to everything people say
and i reach my own judgment i think my
mother would say i'm probably not very
good at taking advice
uh i disagree i think i hear what
everyone says but i will filter it in my
own way so i don't think
i would say anyone's given me good or
bad advice people can tell me what they
like and i will note it
and ponder it and filter it through the
amt view of the world and then reach a
decision so i wouldn't chastise anyone
for giving me bad advice i probably just
dismissed it on the way through she's
still wearing your boss t-shirt
metaphorically so it's still there
under my shirt like a superman t-shirt
um thank you for joining us today it's a
pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
you